hey hey lunar lunar eclipse lunar hey
lunar eclipse I'm relevant hey guys it
is Wednesday here on its face which
means that it is one summer Wednesday or
short I'm wearing a track jacket from my
high school tennis team sweatpants and a
shirt that has stains on it from me
dyeing my hair so that clearly means
that I'm of the right sense to judge
fashion let's talk about the MTV Movie
Awards red carpet fashions that cadence
was off a little PETA last name she's
wearing a dress that is cool and hip and
fun and she's just so cooler than they
will ever be those shoes gonna damn it
you're a role model I'm over all over
rihanna ran out of time in our hotel and
just took the rope with her said i can
make this work watch this
i'm a love interest in any ricky martin
video Jessica Alba oh you're a mom but
you're sexy but your mom you're like a
sexy mmm skittle shailene woodley aka
the star of The Fault no stars you look
like that movie 300 but you are a cute
girl version of it Nicki Minaj I had to
be told that this was Nicki Minaj
because I had sincerely no idea what you
look so muted and sad why so sad you
make a lot of money Rita Ora
where am i what it what what ellie
goulding you're going to a wedding prom
second front it is going to MTV Movie
Awards as Hannah Hart Tyler Oakley ah I
where is that blazer from I need it and
I want it and I need it and I want it
and what a beautiful idiot anyway there
is my review of the MTV Movie Awards I
would give it I don't know
oh that's sanding okay
grumpy cat
I can't